china says experts from the world health
organization
are due in the country this week to
investigate the origins of the
coronavirus pandemic
that's as a fresh outbreak of the virus
spreads near the capital beijing
authorities have put several cities
under a strict lockdown but dozens more
people have tested positive
near beijing is a ghost town
public transport is shut
and martial law has been declared in
this city
of 11 million residents
the lockdown came as a surprise to me
we haven't been allowed to go to work
for the last few days
nor have we been allowed out we had to
wait three days to do a second
coronavirus test
children haven't been allowed to go to
school we have to wait to do more tests
we don't know what the schools are going
to do either
fear of another outbreak is gripping
china
the authorities are trying to implement
measures quickly
to prevent these local cases from
spreading
streets are being disinfected more than
20 new infections
have been reported per day the millions
of people confined to their homes have
been told to stay there for at least 10
days
and avoid leaving loudspeakers tell
residents
that health workers will carry out
coronavirus tests
in their homes
residents are allowed to venture out to
buy food
many have been stocking up on basics
like rice and eggs
coronavirus tests have been carried out
on mass this week
special labs have been set up too
chinese state television reports say
infection numbers
are expected to drop
president xi jinping has declared a
people's war against the virus
and even celebrated victory against it
in september
by honoring those who fought to bring an
end to the covet 19 pandemic
this marks another feat in the history
of humanity's struggle
against the virus
but the war isn't over yet around 50
million people are expected to be
vaccinated by the start of the chinese
new year celebrations
in mid-february this year the government
has warned people not to travel during a
holiday that normally sees millions take
trips to visit family